on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-handed veteran johnny cueto
johnny cueto in his 14th year at the big
league level he's 35 years of age this
is what he has done this year in eight
starts four and one with a three four
five era 36 strikeouts against six walks
and with uh johnny quito you're going to
see a fastball hill two and four seam
he's got a slider curveball change up
sinker i mean he
not a whole lot that he won't throw we
all love
the way that he throws it this is popped
up
wilmer flores is going to have to do the
pop-up dance here it comes
and he makes the catch
here's bryant
got him 94. here's ian happ
q shot base hit
and probably a double hustling over into
foul ground near the tarp cylinder to
pick it up is the left fielder dickerson
and then the second goes hap with a
double here's baez
solano near the bag
side retired
on the hill today for the cubs will be
the right-handed veteran kyle hendricks
hendricks in his seventh year at the big
league level he's 31 years of age out of
newport beach california you take your
bats against them you're going to see a
guy who pitches under the the average
hitting speed his fastball will be a
high 80s to four and two seem he's got a
good curveball but a great changeup and
he'll throw anything at any time a very
very
consistent control specialist
wade goes the other way
bryant back brian at the wall he leaps
[Applause]
out of here
on the first pitch of the game from kyle
hendricks lamont way junior plants one
in the left field bleachers to give the
giants an instantaneous one-nothing lead
and that's just stunned kyle hendricks
take a look at the pitch
fastball away stays right down through
it catches it with backspin and then
watch the carry
there was no batting practice today so
we had no idea how the wind is playing
here for the longest time we thought
chris bryant who's 6-5 had a chance at
it i think he did touch it buster
hitting 321 with 10 home runs
buster lines this one into center field
evasive
here's duggar posey goes
posey at second duggar at first here's
solano hope for one lifetime against
hendricks
a little flare to right and a base hit
and here's the challenge
and here's the throw
not in time
hayward with a bad throw it's two
nothing
ron wonders took a shot
that's an aggressive call because
hayward has a good arm and posey i mean
he had a great jump but still he's below
average speed two nothing giant second
inning patrick wisdom the batter
that's drilled to center will struck
duggar back near the wall out of here
straight away center field he's hit
another
patrick wisdom with number six it comes
around the board yeah
he is loving life right now patrick
wisdom making up for lost time
one-time top prospect turned into a
quote-unquote journeyman
but he's playing like an all-star right
now kyle hendricks is back to work here
in the bottom of the second mauricio
dubai leads off
hooked on the left field line nobody's
there
duvan who can run is going to end up at
second base
and he's got a lead off double just like
that hendricks right back in the
in the stretch
and with a runner and score position
now here's buster
out into right center field is anybody
there
absolutely not
buster's gonna have a double it's three
to one
some on that pitch alex dickerson the
batter he is having a great year
in line to the center that's a basic
half will pick it up they send the
rudder
throw to the plate tag
out
he and half leading off the fourth
inning doubled his first time they've
had two hits today hap takes high that's
ball four that's a gift half to second
with two down and patrick wisdom who
belted a home run his first time will
face johnny cueto
again that's drilled to center well
struck this ball's back it's got a
chance he's done it again
patrick wisdom
a blast to center field
his second two homer game of the year
and on homer number seven we're starting
over tied at three that was smoke
this is just incredible what a story
this is becoming patrick wisdom the
journeyman just just playing lights out
that's ripped down the line and that's a
fair ball it's going to get into the
corner
and kyle's got himself a double how do
you like that
that'll bring up anthony rizzo who's 0
for 2 this afternoon against johnny
cueto
that one back up the middle and it gets
under the glove of dubon
hendricks takes a turn
and he'll stay put
grizzle hit a rocket right back up the
middle and now the bases will be loaded
for baez bobby waits here it comes
on the ground softly hit
coming home
and it gets away from posey as the run
comes in to score
and it's 4-3 cubs
he just didn't look at all the way in
yeah boy but that's sloppy
and what a break for the cubs
i mean the throw is low
certainly one that posey should have
caught
so connor yeah
he will face
hayward with the bases loaded
got him he struck him out slider
breaking down and away and right out of
the strike zone
but the inning is not over yet here
comes patrick wisdom got him and that'll
end the inning nice job finish out
number two eyeing run 90 feet away
wilmer flurries batting to pera 3-1
and that one lifted out there towards
right center hayward there has it and
tupera
does a good job to get out of trouble
greg kimbrell will go to work on the
giants here in the bottom of the ninth
inning mauricio dubon to lead it off for
the giants here on the ninth inning
kimbrell deals
and that one drilled in the air left
field going back right near the wall he
caught it
he caught it chris bryan
stole extra bases from dubon what a play
great timing on the jump the glove was
right near the top of the wall
when he snatched it out number one what
a play giants down to their last out oh
and two now kimbrell ready
and fires
in there got em ball game
cubs win
and they salvage the finale
and avoid the swede thanks to that guy
patrick wisdom another two homer game